welcome to this video against epic
effects okay plate him once and lost so
this is the clear up sorry and this is a
clear kind of indication what I should
do in this game let's try to win this
okay get the Kings Indian can you try
something else there okay let's just
continue with my experimentation of this
with this line yeah they keep playing
this this gung-ho variation where no
he's playing it differently um that's
now transposing into that looks a lot
like them by your net now do I want to
play Bishop e3 I don't know Bishop e3 or
takes an A for one of the two let's see
okay no he's coming up with this really
you can allow c5 okay if I'm able to
play the move I will play the move
without thinking too long about it it's
probably the right recipe if I go on if
go to you for now
not quite get get it looks like it's
opening up to my advantage maybe not but
looks looks like it 326 and I guess okay
the night on f5 is currently come check
things then going to be five that was my
idea
checking v6 and really such a big
decision okay maybe a maybe he wants to
go to e7 oh that that could be that
might be might be an interesting idea
covering the pawn there with the bishop
no now it's not a bad idea maybe now is
playing in a much more ambitious in
fashion it's a bit hard to believe that
you can afford that without having
anything near like complete development
but maybe 97 96 I don't know
and night i'm not sure about 97 36 if
this is really good okay the idea is
very officer to take and play something
only three and a night only three
yeah I smell it that's as as mentioned
that's very ambitious but maybe not so
bad this one very tricky night rookie
this reason isn't as bad as I thought
so I'm attacking III here I mean which
is not a serious threat but anyway let's
see what he does 94 maybe maybe 90 form
Jeff alia III was was kind of good but I
didn't really think so at first but it
seems totally I'll gave him now I cannot
take queen bee three was probably not
the best idea Adam
wow that lipstick doesn't look really
great Chris b3 you want to have what a
howler huh yeah I should have calculated
a little bit that just not move it
that's really a bad position you can
just take it to them community X rugae
for I mean I cannot Knight takes rook
takes Bishop g4 probably
whatever yet you three is really
interesting what should have played
there I mean definitely not cleaned III
but I really have really wonder what I
should have played
yeah now he's falling asleep down just
nights just 92 is good anything better
maybe there's something better Queen B 6
or something I don't know but 92 is so
simple I go to check to rook takes
Bishop g4 yeah we should be six rupee
eight it's awkward but what can you do
maybe then Quincy to checking a four and
the checking or looking at c8 maybe 97
is the move attacking the rook down
for example after Luke a five I can go
nite c7 maybe chap very tricky position
and not clear to me at all my pieces
look a bit shaky but yeah well he has
his coordination issues issues as well
why can I not take the rook this is the
important question I don't see why this
was the idea the ship's e5 let's f6
hanging at the end that's very important
so queen bee 50 what is this I don't
look what okay calm down what is this
I'm going to take care right check yeah
I only have one move
after Bishop b5 I don't I can take with
the Queen and my rook is protected then
of f1 chat 1 yeah I can take with the
Queen time ironing resigns I was a bit
of a lucky game I totally totally
underestimated III m check I don't know
so it looks kind of normal but yeah that
is strong that's really strong yeah my
lack of knowledge of those middle games
is showing I really did not appreciate
that at all I probably should go there
and to simply prevent that hmm that's
probably better this is this is really
quite quite something and now III yeah
that that's good it's good I absolutely
absolutely made the wrong call there
when I said that it looked strange to me
but it looked strange because I felt
like well I what I didn't really
understood i think is now that i look at
it um out of the game like after the
game when you have a little bit of a
clearer way of judging things i was
thinking he should kind of try to yeah
complete development but he doesn't need
to were the rookies developed where
should the bishop go and the Queen has
to be on da probably so it was kind of
nervous a misjudgment III is just good
yeah of course and queen bee three is
terrible the comp wants to play this
with
yeah this is this would be rather nice I
mean they are not spectacularly great
but kind of harmonious and this is just
not working check and here yeah this is
stir it's really really bad yea he
checked there I thought that was totally
normal but the computer actually says
that this is not so great computer wants
to do this which it did not really have
on my radio but okay yeah there is a
point to it yeah just setting up the pin
down yeah it's very awkward really very
awkward yeah I have to probably play
this ugly move say I know we should be a
five is what the computer suggesting my
it's really terrible now check but I'm
surprised that this wasn't so great I
really thought that this should be good
for black kind of but maybe maybe it's
not so clear computers has equal
amazingly enough with bishop c7 however
this bad I I guess that move okay that
makes lots of sense and black us better
again nobody blundered with that him and
just take this not sure if he if you
overload something there that's really
not working at all yeah I was a lucky
win really I end up at e3 that actually
I already have to block the e porn they
are not letting it go forward up to e3
that's really am a huge swing yeah in
the position where black is immediately
better okay well thanks for watching